ok vamos a hacer un motor muy parecido
al que usa una secadora más simple pero
con los mismos principios entonces vamos
a empezar con un bloque de madera que
nos sobre y vamos a marcar las esquinas
para saber en dónde está el centro solo
como punto de referencia también
necesitamos un poco de alambre de cobre
magneto que es el mismo tipo de alambre
que usa este tipo de motores también
vamos a necesitar imanes permanentes
entonces vamos a encontrar el lugar en
el que podemos montar todo esto y para
eso primero determinemos como pondremos
los imanes vamos a asegurarnos de que
los imanes estén orientados
correctamente es decir que los polos
estén opuestos y también tenemos dos
arandelas que usaremos como soportes
entonces vamos a hacer un campo del
tamaño de esta tapa
ahorita sólo estoy posicionando todas
las piezas que necesitaremos y estoy
viendo en donde los colocaré y qué tan
cerca y claro la tapa será la estructura
de nuestro circuito entonces las
arandelas que soportarán el circuito
tienen que estar muy cerca de la tapa al
igual que los imanes permanentes
entonces solo estoy haciendo las marcas
para que podamos colocar todo en su
lugar y es muy importante que todo esté
alineado exactamente porque si no el
circuito no funcionará bien entonces
vamos a decir que la primera medida se
encuentra aproximadamente a una pulgada
del centro ok ahora que ya tenemos las
marcas de nuestros puntos de
intersección vamos a perforar los
orificios para eso usaré una broca de
media pulgada sólo quiero que el hueco
sea de media pulgada y después vamos a
usar una de tres dieciseisavos en dos de
los lados y después una de 8 pulgadas
para los otros dos lados porque los
otros lados van a sujetar los soportes
ok aquí van los soportes y bueno como
tenía unos tornillos que me sobraban de
una cama los voy a usar
y estos son otros tornillos que tenía
pero ustedes pueden usar cualquier
tornillo o clavo que tengan lo
importante es que estén bien alineados y
que estén al mismo nivel así mejorará la
eficiencia de nuestro motor entonces hay
que revisar el nivel y asegurarse de que
todo esté bien alineado ahora voy a usar
un poco de pegamento caliente pero antes
voy a asegurarme de que los imanes
permanentes estén orientados
correctamente para que se atraigan entre
ellos y solo estoy poniendo un poco de
pegamento caliente en el tornillo para
pegar el imán ok así es muy fácil
cambiar la posición de los imanes que
tal vez lo necesitemos después y bueno
aquí tengo una arandela y voy a pegarla
en su lugar con una orientación vertical
el pegamento caliente nos permite hacer
ajustes fácilmente y bueno ahora vamos a
tomar la tapa de la botella y vamos a
envolverla con el alambre para crear
nuestra bobina vamos a darle siete
vueltas
y una vez que tenemos nuestra bobina
dejando aproximadamente 3 pulgadas de
sobrante en cada lado vamos a enrollarlo
un poco para que no quede flojo y quede
más firme
y después hacemos lo mismo con el otro
lado simplemente enrollamos el alambre
y así nuestro circuito queda más firme y
nos permitirá colocarlo en las arandelas
ok ahora sólo voy a cubrir una parte del
alambre para que quede bien fijo aquí
estoy usando una cinta aislante pero
ustedes pueden usar cualquier cinta que
tenga ahora en este caso el alambre está
aislado aunque no lo parezca tiene un
recubrimiento muy delgado así que ahora
lo que necesitamos hacer para que el
flujo de energía pueda pasar a través
del alambre voy a raspar un poco para
quitar ese recubrimiento en uno de los
lados y observen que estoy rotando el
alambre eso es importante porque si solo
le rascan un poco no es suficiente si
quieren asegurarse de que toda esta
parte del alambre esté completamente
limpia retiren el aislante conforme lo
vayan raspando y podrán sentir la
diferencia una vez que lo hayan quitado
porque el alambre se sentirá un poco más
áspero que antes
ahora me di cuenta de que los imanes
estaban demasiado cerca así que
simplemente los despegue y los
reposiciones nuevamente ok entonces aquí
simplemente estoy haciendo algunos
ajustes y lo que sucede es que la
corriente fluye desde la batería a
través de la arandela y hacia la bobina
creando un electroimán de un lado de la
bobina empujamos contra el polo positivo
del imán y del otro lado empujamos
contra el polo sur de lima- eso provoca
que la bobina gire y antes de eso la
electricidad va desde el final de la
bobina de regreso a las baterías y
después la bobina gira y el proceso se
repite entonces aquí lo que sucede es
que la bobina está funcionando como un
electroimán empujando contra nuestros
imanes permanentes girando una y otra
vez ahora esta bobina solamente consta
de un ciclo pero el motor de una
secadora tiene cinco ciclos por eso se
le conoce como un motor de cinco polos
ahora veamos si podemos usar este motor
para generar trabajo tomaré una arandela
y voy a marcar algunos círculos en una
hoja de papel y después con unas tijeras
voy a cortar los círculos para poder
hacer un pequeño ventilador ahora el
motor que hicimos no es muy poderoso así
que haremos un ventilador pequeño y
ligero pero ya verán que se moverá y
demostrará el principio aquí simplemente
estoy enrollando un poco cada una de las
aspas para que se vean como un
ventilador real y lo voy a poner en uno
de los extremos de la bobina
también pondré un poco de pegamento para
mantenerlo ahí
y ahora vamos a darle vueltas y veamos
si podemos hacer que el motor gire y nos
muestre algún trabajo
y ahí está
y bueno uno de los experimentos que tal
vez quieran intentar es por ejemplo qué
pasa cuando quitamos uno de los imanes
si tenemos los dos en cada lado
qué pasa cuando quitamos uno o qué pasa
cuando volteamos uno de los imanes
haciendo que los mismos polos queden
frente a frente y si tienen suficiente
alambre magnético tal vez quieran
intentar raspar todo el alambre y ver
qué pasa o no respaldó y ver qué pasa
sigue girando por qué o por qué no
o tal vez también quieran intentar hacer
varios sistemas y ver si eso cambia el
rendimiento del motor espero que les
haya gustado